اوكرانيا تنتظر بقلق معركه الربيع وتتحضر
لها بحشد الدعم العسكري الغربي في انتظار
استلام دفعه من الدبابات الا ان امامها
معضله فوضى الانواع حسب توقعات خبراء
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست حسب شكوك الخبراء قدره
تلك الدبابات على الحسن في ساحه المعركه
مرهونه بامور عده اولها احتمال تصعد
الروسي العسكري خاصه مع تزويد كيف باسلحه
هجوميه لا دفاعيه كما تبرز معضلات تقنيه
امام اوكرانيا حيث تتسلم خريطه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ويخلق حاله من الفوضى
الاهم من ذلك هو ان القوات الاوكرانيه غير
قادره على التعامل مع تلك الانواع من
الدبابات فهي بحاجه للتدريب على استخدامها
في جبهه القتال قد يعني ان التدريب سيتم
خارج حدودها ثم انك
تحتاج كي تتمكن من تشغيل تلك الدبابات الى
الدعم اللوجستي والصيانه وقطع الغيار بشكل
فوري وسريع
اوكرانيا التي قدرت اضرار الحرب
138 مليار دولار تمسكت بان المساعدات
الغربيه قد تشكل تغييرا في قواعد اللعبه
العسكريه الا ان خبراء عسكريين لواشنطن
بوست يارون انه لا يمكن لاي نظام او منصه
اسلحه بمفردها ان تغير قواعد اللعبه وانه
بدون حل المشكله اللوجستيه قد تجازف
اوكرانيا بالحفاظ على ايقاعها على ارض
المعركه